this just off the wire reuter news is
reporting now
that the mike tyson app has just raped
another app
okay
all right stay tuned for more of the
sammy davis junior tribute honoring the
one heavyweight i would never dare step
into the ring with
sammy you're a true undefeated champ
wait
i think mike can do a little better than
that mike
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna attempt to read
this this may be disastrous
okay stay tuned for more of the sammy
davis junior trivia
honoring the one heavyweight i would
never dare step into the ring with
sammy you are truly the undefeated
champion
the producers of the show the producers
of the show was hoping you'd have a
little more
feeling more mike you know a little bit
more mike tyson
you know more mike tysonisms like like
hello ladies and gentlemen sammy and i
would
like
[Applause]
if you go to prison it's hard to get a
job but like you can walk out of prison
and do an open mic within the first week
and people will put you on
they won't give a [ __ ] dude they'd be
like dude you should wear your [ __ ]
orange jumpsuit
you killed somebody do you should talk
about that that'd be funny like they
wouldn't give a [ __ ]
i thought you were laughing you were
[ __ ] yawning over here no the
mushrooms were [ __ ]
killing me man i knew it wasn't just
weed i was just like there's no way i'm
taking a hit off of that there's
something going on here mushrooms baby
the shrooms i'm shrooming
[Laughter]
he's shrooming and he's wearing pants
like he went riding a horse today
like side saddle or some [ __ ]
don't be like my wife my wife is like
dick patrol man don't be like checking
out my [ __ ] tight pants and [ __ ]
my wife's always judging my tight
[ __ ] clothes and [ __ ] don't be like
that
i never thought mike tyson and the
reason i'm saying this because
[ __ ] now he's fighting like
farmers they got mike fighting
anybody just to say mike we want to see
you knock a [ __ ]
out again he was so special as a
knockout artist we hated to see him when
he got on the rape beef
that i never believe especially based on
the last interview we had
with uh greta van suskin and
he goes she goes what do you have to say
to your victims mike
he goes well i wish i had to really rape
the [ __ ]
[Music]
and her mama i wish i had to really rape
the [ __ ] and her mama
i'm like oh that is an innocent man
that's the
i'm telling you only an innocent man
could be that angry and say some [ __ ]
that [ __ ] up
like i i wish i had a rape decide i'd
been in jail for something instead of
raping a [ __ ] and i really didn't
so that's mike's way of like figuring it
all out
and her testimony years ago which cut me
off
even without the interview but interview
solidified it
her testimony he forced oral sex on me
and i said damn he made you suck his
dick that's terrible
he ate a [ __ ] that's when it was like
case
case dismissed cause what rapist tries
to make you feel wonderful i
i've been eating [ __ ] in a long time
and i never eat it rapey how the [ __ ] do
you go shout out [ __ ] shut up
shut up my ninja [ __ ] shut up
i peel away the outer lips and
slide the hood back to expose your
clitoris
for maximum stimulation shut the [ __ ] up
you can't even make a mean face while
you eat [ __ ] you can't you be like shut
[Applause]
you better not be enjoying this [ __ ]
[Applause]
has any woman here be getting a [ __ ]
eating them and going hell
police owe me
my [ __ ] somebody do something shut up
nobody hear you cries
all right the boxing world is still
buzzing after the release of mike tyson
from an indiana prison
after serving a three-year term here
with a message for mike
his weekend update correspondent and my
hero adam sandler
hey uh by the way uh mr tyson this is a
norm mcdonald he's our new update guy
you'll love him he's been telling the
funniest jokes about you giving it up in
prison
mr tyson i'm uh i'm not norm mcdonald i
don't even know who nor mcdonald is
i'm kevin nealon and that's news to me
[Music]
nah but the boxes man like mike tyson i
wish people would stop [ __ ] with mike
tyson
people say mike should be banned from
boxing he should like [ __ ] that
when he bit evander holyfield's ear that
[ __ ] was making money do you
really want him on the streets broke
loose and mad
keep that [ __ ] busy at all times give
him some blocks or something let him
scariest [ __ ] i ever saw with mike tyson
no mike tyson did an interview in jail
this was right after the rape conviction
montel williams said mike since you've
been in prison
has any other inmates try to [ __ ] with
you and mike said the scariest [ __ ] i
ever heard that mother said
you know a couple times guys tried to
cause problems but i just pulled them
aside and i whispered in the air after
that was never a problem
and i'm thinking what the [ __ ] could he
tell a murderer to make him go i'm not
[ __ ] with this [ __ ]
like mike just said listen you keep
[ __ ] with me i'ma knock you out and
[ __ ] you till you wake up
you don't want to be that [ __ ] you
don't want to wake up to this [ __ ]
i told you i'm serious stop [ __ ] with
me